- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is "Believe,"
and I believe that you
have something special,
that when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is,
stop doing the wrong things.
Over to you, Jordan B. Peterson.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Stop doing the things
that you know are wrong,
that you could stop doing.
Right, so it's a fairly limited attempt,
first of all, we're not
going to say that you know
what the good is, or what the truth is,
in any ultimate sense.
But we will presume that there are things
that you're doing, that
for one reason or other,
you know are not in your best interests.
There's something about them,
that you just know you should stop.
They're kind of self-evident to you.
Other things you're going
to be doubtful about.
You're not going to know which way is up,
and which way is down.
But there are things that you're doing,
that you know you shouldn't do.
Now, some of those you won't stop doing.
For whatever reason, you
don't have the discipline,
or maybe there's a secondary payoff, or,
you don't believe it's
necessary, or it's too much
of a sacrifice, or, you're angry,
or, resentful, or, afraid, who knows.
So forget about those for now.
But there's another subset
that you could stop doing.
It might be a little thing.
Well, that's fine, stop doing it.
And see what happens.
And what'll happen is, your
vision will clear a little bit.
And then, something else
will pop up, in your field
of apprehension, that you
will also know you should
stop doing, and that you could stop doing.
Cause you strengthened yourself a bit,
by stopping doing the
particular stupid thing
that you were doing before.
That just puts you
together a little bit more.
And you could do that repeatedly,
for an indefinite period of time.
And, you know, that doesn't
necessarily mean that
you're going to ever be
able to formulate a clear,
and final picture of what
constitutes the truth,
and the good, but it does mean, that,
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth, and what's bad.
And, you know, that's not a bad start.
(whoosh sound effect)
- So I love the message of
stop doing the wrong things.
I think it's vitally important,
the question then becomes, how?
And if we're eliminating the
things that Jordan Peterson
said are giving us some kind
of benefit, then the ones
that are left, at least in
my opinion, are the ones
that are giving you fear.
The ones that you are afraid
of doing, and so that you
don't go out and do it,
or the fear is making you
continue to do it.
And so for me, whenever
there's been that kind of fear,
I'm doing something, or
I'm not doing something
out of fear, the solution
has always been to create
a bigger fear in the future,
and bring it back to today.
It's not, pretend like
the fear doesn't exist.
that big scary thing
that you have to go and do, isn't real,
it's just, I make the
future fear a lot bigger
than the current fear.
And so think about that thing
that you wish you can go and do.
Think about that project that
you really want to start,
or that person that you
really want to talk to,
that connection you really want to make.
Whatever the thing is, that's
kind of gnawing at you,
that you really really
really want to go out and do.
But you're not, because you're afraid.
Think about your life, you know,
when you're 80, 90, you
know, 200 years old.
And then, look back on this moment.
And the fact that you did
not take action on it,
has now lead to a life
of decades of regret.
And I try to make that
as painful as possible.
As real and painful as possible.
And bring that back to right now, so that,
I'm so afraid of the future fear,
that I have to go and take action.
And it doesn't mean that always works out.
A lot of times it may
not work out, you know.
You may get rejected,
that deal may not work.
You know, you may lose money on something.
But for me, knowing is the key.
I can deal with failure.
I can deal with something not working out.
Hopefully I don't make it
a huge, colossal failure.
I could deal with the failure, but what
I can't deal with, is not knowing.
And so two quick examples
I want to share with you.
One, there was this
event called Climber Con
in California, earlier this year,
and I hate going to events
where I'm not speaking,
I don't like networking,
I don't like going
to conferences, it's just not something
that I enjoy doing.
But it was for YouTubers with
100,000 plus subscribers,
and some of the people
that I knew were going,
that I had kind of met
virtually, and I thought,
this might be something
that I should go to.
For once, an event looked interesting,
for me to go to as a participant,
and not as a speaker.
And I was hemming and hawing,
like, ah, should I go,
should I not go, and I delayed really long
before, I eventually buy
my ticket, and I just
came to the point where, I'm
going to regret not going.
I can deal with it not working
out, I can deal with it
being a total bust, meeting
nobody, making no connections,
wasting my time, wasting my money to go,
I could deal with that, and if anything,
it would prove my point
that networking events suck,
and I'm never going to
go to another one again.
But I needed to know.
And so I booked my ticket, and I went,
and it was okay.
You know, I probably just
got my money's worth.
It wasn't amazing, it wasn't
some huge success story,
but I made some new connections,
I got to go face to face
with some people that
I had met before, and,
I learned a couple of things.
So it was not, a little
bit positive, right.
Another example, when I
was promoting my book,
I worked with a number of
different people to help me
promote it, different agencies,
different connections,
and there was one, who,
had a reputation that
looked really interesting,
and gave me a proposal,
and, I was a little
skeptical of doing it, but,
again, I felt like
if I didn't say yes, I would regret it.
And so, I said yes.
And, to be honest, it
didn't really work out.
You know, I paid a lot of money.
I didn't get, I didn't get the result.
I didn't get my money's worth at all.
I didn't get zero value,
but I didn't get the value
that I felt I had paid for.
But it's okay.
Like, it's a lesson learned,
and I'm not going to live
the next 90 years with regret, that,
I didn't say yes, and you're wondering,
what if, what if, what
if, what if, what if.
You know, there's been other
times where it has worked out,
insanely well, when I
worked with my agent,
for the first time, I
almost didn't say yes.
I was on the fence, and I just felt like
I might regret it, and it worked out
really really really well.
I got a lot better on camera.
My YouTube channel started to explode.
I got a book deal, and
other opportunities.
And so, don't be so
attached to the outcome,
of it working or not working, right.
Like it has to work, or
it was a huge failure.
For me, it's much more, if
there's something that I
feel like I might regret,
and you're just delaying
and delaying and delaying,
eventually, that window's going to close,
you're going to miss your opportunity.
And so, make that future fear so big,
bring it back to today, and say,
I'm going to regret this for
the next 90 years of my life,
I need to know.
You could deal with it not
working out, you could deal
with failure, you could
deal with the rejection,
but what you can't deal
with, is not knowing.
So the question today, I'm curious,
what is that thing that's gnawing at you,
that you really want to try,
you really want to test,
you really want to go out
and do, but you're afraid.
What is that thing for you
right now, in your business,
in your life, leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Wim Winters.
Wim, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word," I really
appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning,
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter sound effect)
- What you focus on, grows.
What you focus on, grows.
If you focus on problems,
problems will multiply.
If you focus on opportunities,
opportunities will multiply.
You have to choose what you're
going to spend your time on.
See, every day, you're either
getting better or worse.
You don't stay the same in life.
People don't stay the same.
They're either getting
better, or they're worse.
You're not a human being.
You're a human becoming.
Okay, every day,
(audience applauds)
you are changing your lives.
And you are every day becoming
your current, most dominant thought.
Not what you say you're thinking about,
not what you tell other
people you're doing,
you are becoming what you're thinking.
Napoleon Hill said,
"Thoughts are things."
(audience applauds)
Thoughts aren't,
thoughts aren't random
electrode, you know,
synapses between nerve endings.
Thoughts are things.
What are you allowing to be in your brain?
What are you focusing on?
What are you spending your time on?
Who influences you?
- A human being does not become who he is,
because of his desire.
He becomes who he is,
because of his competence.
So in enhancing your competence,
you're just enhancing
your desire, which will be
just a horrible burden
to carry all the time.
You just focus on enhancing the competence
of who this is, rather
than enhancing your desire,
I'm going to become a world champion.
Everybody wants to become one.
They're not going to become one.
Isn't it?
Everybody wants to be successful.
They will not be a success.
Unless you do the right things.
Success will not happen to you.
Can I tell you a joke?
(audience laughs)
Forty-five minutes?
You got to be serious.
- Joke now?
- We can?
- You want to joke?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- You need to joke?
- Yes.
- Okay, let me ask you this question.
- No, let me tell you a joke.
(audience laughs)
- Even better.
- On a certain day, a man,
fell into a septic tank.
And right up to here in filth.
He desperately tried to come out.
He could not.
Then he started screaming, "Fire, fire!"
Neighbors heard this,
called the fire brigade.
Firemen came rushing, they
looked all over the place,
no fire, then they found this man.
They pulled him out, and then they asked,
"Why were you screaming
fire? Where is the fire?"
The man retorted, "If I said
shit, shit, would you come?"
(audience laughs)
You got to do the right things.
Otherwise right things
will not happen to you.
Just because you have a big desire,
you're not going to get there,
you got to do the right things.